ready for some lunch is that really what
we're having Brody have I ever steered
you wrong I'm gonna show you how we make
a frozen pizza a little less I've got
some steamed broccoli here and some
little baby Tomatoes I've got some
leftover rotisserie chicken here some
olives
a little bit of nooch nutritional yeast
extra cheese because why not and some
toasted pine nuts
then we just throw it in the oven
[Music]
and Brody this is the magic a little
spicy honey come on wow that really does
look
all right Brody listen up we've got lots
of fiber in all of our added veg plus
some added protein in our new and our
chicken healthy fats in our olives and
our pine nuts and some hot honey to
bring it up a notch you're not gonna cut
muffy's